this hearing is on the oversight of our
artificial intelligence the first in a
series of hearings intended to write the
rules
of AI
and now uh for some introductory remarks
too often
we have seen what happens when
technology outpaces regulation
the unbridled exploitation of personal
data the proliferation of disinformation
and the deepening of societal
inequalities
we have seen how algorithmic biases can
perpetuate discrimination and Prejudice
and how the lack of transparency can
undermine public Trust
this is not the future we want
if you were listening from home you
might have thought that voice was mine
and the words
from me but in fact that voice was not
mine
the words were not mine
and the audio was an AI voice cloning
software trained on my floor speeches
the remarks were written by chat gbt
I am sure that we'll look back in a
decade and uh view chat GPT and gpt4
like we do the first cell phone those
big clunky things that we use to carry
around but we recognize that we are on
the verge really of a new era